[MUSIC]
You can't think of a body-friendly old days 6
That's the kind of woman I told
you to make me a palace
Other kids
hate me and interest  Open I
understand It's
easy to read It's too much to fall The curly craft work is heavy But you're a wonderful man
Here's the worst woman
Axis
Pharmaceuticals over here
I'll be serious today so as not to bore you I'm serious
I told you before
We have councils depending on skill level
First activity Next formation
Your level is still up to that level
But I'm 4
I'm
Niju-kun, I've
decided not to forget my oath to make my wish come true
!
No
, it's hard to stop at 9. Yeah, yeah,
village.
This one can't be cut. It's
broken.